[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia soy álvaro cordero la invasión
rusa ucrania ha ocupado el foco
mediático de los últimos días por su
gran importancia vladimir putin hizo
referencia en uno de sus discursos
previos al ataque ruso al origen de
ucrania y llegó a desconocer que este
país tenga una tradición de estado
genuino pero es esto cierto para
averiguarlo lo mejor es penetrar en la
historia de ucrania y definir los lazos
que han unido y unen a los dos países
para ello toca remontarse a tiempos de
la luz de kiev esta federación de tribus
eslavas dominó una gran parte de la
estepa europea entre los siglos 9 y 13
durante la dinastía rubrica se pasó del
paganismo eslavo al cristianismo
ortodoxo en el año 900 87 base
fundamental para el forjamiento de una
cultura común que reclaman tanto rusia
como ucrania pero no se puede hablar de
un estado ucraniano en sí hasta 1917 ese
año el imperio ruso se retira de la
primera guerra mundial y en el
territorio ucraniano se desata un vacío
de poder alentado por la guerra civil
ruso
es en este contexto que se crea en quien
la república popular ucraniana su
territorio era algo más grande que el
actual pero durante su existencia hubo
múltiples enfrentamientos internos y su
control de facto nunca fue real hasta
que en 1921 sucumbió ante la república
polaca y los bolcheviques rusos el oeste
de ucrania quedó bajo control polaco
mientras que en el resto del territorio
se creó en 1922 la república socialista
soviética de ucrania los años siguientes
estuvieron marcados por la rusificación
del territorio y la persecución del
nacionalismo ucraniano bajo el mando de
stalin se sufrió una gran hambruna entre
1932 y 1934 el conocido como holodomor
se estima que sólo en ucrania murieron
entre 15 y 4 millones de personas aunque
podían ser hasta 12 millones en el resto
de los territorios de la urss tras la
caída de la unión soviética se
descubrieron fuertes indicios de que
estas hambrunas fueron provocadas algo
que ha hecho que ucrania y otra veintena
de países
genocidio pero los desastres
humanitarios continuaron para ucrania la
segunda guerra mundial trajo la invasión
de la alemania nazi en 1941 quien sufrió
dos asedios uno en 1941 que propició la
entrada alemana y otro en 1943 con la
reconquista soviética durante la
invasión hubo apoyos ucranianos a los
alemanes aunque con el tiempo la
hostilidad nazi hizo que esta simpatía
de cayera en el conflicto fallecieron
cientos de miles de ucranianos
en 1953 falleció stalin un hecho
histórico clave que trajo al poder a
nikita khrushchev quien inició una
desestalinización y permitió la anexión
de crimea ucrania en 1956 el territorio
tenía una mayoría rusa pero el
movimiento fue considerado algo
simbólico porque el poder seguía en
moscú sin embargo esta acción traería
consecuencias en el futuro
el dominio soviético comenzó a
languidecer tras el mayor accidente
nuclear de la historia el 26 de abril de
1986 explotó uno de los reactores de la
central nuclear de chernóbil el desastre
contaminó miles de kilómetros cuadrados
con niveles de radiación muy altos y
golpeó seriamente a la reputación de la
urss no se sabe actualmente el número de
fallecidos y afectados como causa de esa
radiación pero se estima que fueron
miles es en este contexto en el que
comienza el final de la unión soviética
que se materializa en 1991 el 24 de
agosto de ese año el parlamento
ucraniano declaró la independencia para
después ratificarlo en un referéndum
este paso junto con la posterior firma
del tratado de vela betsa certificaron
el final de la urss y el reconocimiento
de la independencia de ucrania su primer
presidente fue leonid kravchuk aunque
desde 1994 y hasta 2005 el hombre fuerte
en kiev fue leonid kuchmá un político
ligado a moscú en 2005 llegó al poder
víctor yúshchenko el primer presidente
alejado del kremlin tras ganar a viktor
yanúkovich la opción oficialista
favorita la victoria se dio tras las
protestas de miles de personas en la
llamada 'revolución naranja' tras un
balotaje que se tuvo que repetir por
indicios de fraude pero yanukóvich supo
rehacerse y ganar las elecciones de 2010
volviendo a llevar a ucrania a la esfera
más próxima a moscú sin embargo nunca
pudo terminar su mandato entre noviembre
de 2013 y febrero de 2014 miles de
ucranianos contrarios al presidente se
tomaron las calles y lo derrocaron fue
el conocido como euro my dan el pretexto
de las protestas fue la suspensión del
acercamiento a la unión europea la caída
de yanukóvich solo fue el inicio de la
crisis crimea una región de mayoría rusa
aprobó un referendo para unirse a rusia
en marzo de 2014 que no fue reconocido
internacionalmente sin embargo su
anexión se efectuó pese a las protestas
de la comunidad internacional y en junio
las regiones de donets y lugansk votaron
en dos referendos para convertirse en
red populares independientes la razón
fue la misma la mayoría de su población
es rusa
este último paso desató un conflicto
armado entre pro rusos y el poder
central ya en manos del expresidente
petro poroshenko que hasta la fecha ha
dejado más de 14.000 muertos y que no se
ha detenido a pesar de la firma de los
acuerdos de minsk en 2015 y 2016 es en
este contexto en que se produjo la
invasión de vladimir putin y ucrania con
la excusa de que se estaba cometiendo
genocidio contra las poblaciones de done
jets y lugansk el presidente ruso
reconoció sus independencias e intervino
en ucrania pero su ofensiva militar no
se circunscribió a estas regiones sino
que atacó todo el país aún hay muchas
preguntas por resolver en torno al
futuro de ucrania cuyas respuestas
solamente conoce putin con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]